si le président américain s'est montré
rassurant au cours de la dernière fin de
semaine affirmant qu'il ne veut pas de
guerre avec l'iran il n'a pas baissé de
ton pour autant les nouvelles sanctions
économiques qu'il vient de signer et qui
vise à geler des milliards de dollars
d'actifs iranien ont provoqué une
réaction prévisible à téhéran elles sont
insultantes et idiote a déclaré le
président hassan rohani ajoutant qu'à
son avis la maison blanche était
mentalement dérangé rien de moins
donald trump a réagi du tac au tac
fidèle à lui-même il y est allé d'une
rafale de tweet très peu diplomatique
dont celui ci les propos ignorants et
insultant de l'iran montre seulement
qu'il ne comprennent pas la réalité
toute attaque de l'iran contre quoi que
ce soit d'américains se heurtera à des
représailles puissante et écrasante dans
certaines zones
l'écrasement signifiera l'anéantissement
exit john kerry et obama mais
l'escaladent ne se limite pas qu'aux aux
insultes et aux menaces
l'iran a déjà augmenté sa production
d'uranium faiblement enrichi et d'ici
dix jours il a l'intention de
recommencer à fabriquer de l'uranium à
des fins militaires
les pays européens comme la france qui
gardaient leurs distances face à
l'attitude musclée de washington
commencent à s'inquiéter et sommes
téhéran de continuer à respecter
l'accord de vienne dès 2015 l'escaladé
est aussi nucléaire puisque l'iran a
annoncé sa volonté de ne plus respecter
certaines obligations de l'accord de
vienne la prolifération c'est le risque
majeur mais où finit la joute verbale et
où commence un véritable danger d'une
escalade militaire dans une région sous
haute tension
la réaction de l'oranie en réaction tout
à fait inattendu et à briquet le langage
qu'il a utilisée contre trempe démontre
effectivement dit on
me détérioration dans les relations
pendant que la tension monte à téhéran
certains habitants se range derrière
leurs dirigeants contre l'amérique
comme notre cher leader l'ayatollah
khamenei l'a dit les américains ont un
caractère instable et on ne peut pas
leur faire confiance dit celui-ci
mais est ce le cas de la majorité des
iraniens
donald trump ne pourrait-il pas gagné
son pari en mettant une pression maximum
sur les dirigeants provoquer un
changement de régime à terrain la
répression énorme
le gouvernement n'ira bien réussir sur
la majorité de la population
je ne serais pas étonnée étant née de
pouvoir disons beaucoup moins d'appétit
pour confronter un ennemi externe que
par exemple dans le passé quand les
irakiens avaient envahi d'y rentrer dans
ce tome 1980 et une guerre qui a duré
huit ans pendant que les principaux
conseillers de donaldson parcourt la
planète à la recherche de la plus large
coalition possible contre terrain des
experts tirent la sonnette d'alarmé il
abandonne complètement l'entente de
vienne l'iran pourrait obtenir l'armé
nucléaire dans six à huit mois
ici avec sandra schatz qu'à radio-canada
montréal